oeil pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
donc charles pasqua avez raison monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre au nom des
français qui ont appris avec effroi la
décapitation de samuel pâtit un cran de
plus dans l'abomination dans la volonté
des ayatollahs de l'islam d'imposer leur
loi
chez nous élu local en 30 ans j'en ai vu
et entendu des renoncements
j'ai aussi vu cette idéologie
totalitaire gagner nos quartiers
encouragé par la lâcheté coupable de
politique et aussi de technocrates
on a fermé les yeux sur les migrations
massives liées au regroupement familial
sur la création de ghettos urbains sur
la dérive de ces quartiers gangréné par
la drogue de communautarisme et
l'islamisme on a fermé les yeux sur les
motivations réelles de certains migrants
qui viennent pour porter la haine et le
sang on a fermé les yeux sur les coups
de canif à la laïcité les repas de
substitution
les prières de rue les couloirs dans les
piscines le port du voile dans l'espace
public
autant de coups de boutoir portés contre
les fondements de notre république
mais aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas les
fermer les yeux homme seul premier
ministre parce que l'horreur vous a
sauté au visage comme nous tous
d'ailleurs parce qu'il s'est passé à
conflans la même chose qu'à raqqa ou à
mossoul
alors que fait-on aujourd'hui les
français ont compris qu allumé des
bougies et défilé dans la rue n'était
pas un rond par contre cet ennemi qui
veut imposer la charia au ventre mou de
l'occident des français attendent de
vous des actes forts la mise en place
d'une immigration choisie et non pas
imposé par des juges irresponsables
l'expulsion des clandestins des
délinquants étrangers une application
sans faille des règles de la laïcité la
déchéance de nationalité contre tous
ceux qui prennent les armes contre la
mère patrie la reconquête rue par rue de
toutes les zones de non droit un soutien
total à la police si si nécessaire le
renfort de l'armée
pour cela il faut un exécutif déterminer
un parlement respecter car représentant
légitime du peuple ils ne passeront pas
à déclaré le président de la république
le combat donc enfin commencer chez nous
espérons le alors monsieur le premier
ministre dit nous quelles armes
avec quelles armes nous allons combattre
et comment nous pouvons gagner cette
guerre plus de renoncement des actes
s'il vous plaît
pour vous reprendre la parole et
communiquent de l'intérieur au chu lors
madame monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur c'est à
tort même action pas être d'accord sur
le constat on peut différer sur
quelques-unes de vos solutions
d'abord vous faites un lien que j'ai
déjà entendu plusieurs fois pas dans le
tout les représentants du groupe l'est
républicain mais dans quelques-uns qui
consiste à dire étrange et légaliste
amistad égale problème problème égale
terrorisme quand on dit qu'on arrête
totalement l'immigration permettez moi
de vous dire c'est que vous pensez par
nature que tout étranger qui vient sur
le sol national pourrait être un
problème
pardon de le dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui fuient des dictatures
islamistes pour prendre le droit d'asile
en france
des tas de jeunes femmes qui viennent à
l'ofpra demander le droit d'asile pour
pouvoir justement porter cheveux au vent
dans la rue et donc cette caricature me
semble-t-il y compris d'immigration qui
viennent de certains pays arabes
n'honore pas y compris même l'idée que
vous faites de l'affirmation de laïcité
est la vocation universelle de la france
la deuxième des choses c'est que si à
procès à faire sur les naturalisations
et je ne pense pas qu'ils prouvent
s'affairent sur naturalisation c'est
celui peut-être de la majorité monsieur
le député sénateur que nous avons
soutenu moi jeune militant vous
parlementaire 84000 naturalisations par
an entre 2007 et 2012 54000
naturalisations par an sous le président
au maquereau peut-être que cette erreur
et est ancienne et que vous faisiez en
fait votre propre pensée puisque en
regardant bien en regardant bien la
famille la famille la famille de ce
terroriste est arrivé en france sous le
président chirac
elle a eu ses papiers sous le président
sarkozy elle n'a pas été expulsé ce
président hollande et le commet un
attentat sur président macron peut-être
monsieur le sénateur que la question
finalement est simple à poser les
réponses aux difficiles qu'il faut
beaucoup de courage sans doute beaucoup
de courage sans doute pour réparer
beaucoup d'erreurs du passé et c'est
pour ça que c'est un grand honneur
d'être ministre de l'intérieur